if you want something new you have to
give up something old and this is it
this is the path this is a secret I want
you to win you just have to do things
you never think you're gonna have to do
in order to survive
[Music]
rise and shine
it's an espresso time what's up believe
nation its Evan my one word is believe
and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
let's start your day I've right together
grab your coffee and sip on today's
message want it badly enough over to you
dhandapani friend of mine is a new kid
who want a gold medal in all
controllable sorry not bespoke beach
volleyball and so I interviewed her in
Australia a couple months ago when we're
talking about it and I said what drove
you to win I don't know and she knows I
really really wanted it and she didn't
say I really want
yeah and most people don't want it
enough you know and if people ask me you
know it's like how do you go to monster
how do you leave your family behind your
friends everything ice cream chocolate
yeah
Beach you know go anything that you can
imagine and go to the monster for ten
years and no contact yeah because you
want it it just comes down to how much
you really wanted well concentration
willpower practice yes all those so
important those are the ingredients but
how much do you want it if you really
really want it you'll make it way but
most people don't want it enough my
teacher used to say to me all the time
if you want something new you have to
give up something old
yeah we're sitting on the couch and if
you want to bring a brand-new couch in
you would have to get rid of this table
this guy and the sacrifice is such a
good thing you have to give up
you always do a different thing parts of
your life in order to gain something new
but you have to want it you really
really have to want it and that's why
they go from one self-help book to
another self-help book which another
self-help book and they say well you're
not making the best pots out of here and
then it's like a buffet you know you
just pick what you want and you never
commit to anything find one thing commit
to it your actions are not matching your
ambition that's the problem you've got
big aspirations a big mouth big hopes
big dreams you're talking a big game but
you're not doing the actual steps your
calendar what's in your calendar your
actions that you're doing on a daily
basis do not map to you accomplishing
your goals and so what ends up happening
is you're gonna jump from one video to
another video to one seminar to another
seminar getting motivated getting pumped
up and it lasted for a couple hours and
then it fading and you fall back to
regular mediocrity day in day out with
these little blips these little moments
of hyperactivity and energy and momentum
and then the rest flatlining you need to
learn how to schedule for success and
I'm gonna show you how to do it step
number one is make a list of all your
goals all your goals like what is the
life that you want
what is the life that you want to be
living how do you want to be spending
your time what are you
goals and put everything on there and
this is not just a business goal in
entrepreneurial goal that's definitely a
huge part of it right what are those
goals but how what kind of father do you
want to be what kind of mother what kind
of boyfriend/girlfriend daughter son
your personal goals how much time do you
want to spend out in nature how much
time you want to spend out traveling
like what are your goals get super clear
on the life that you want to be living
for you yourself not anybody else's
opinions judgements expectations of what
a good life a balanced life a proper
life is supposed to look like for you
what is your life make a list of all the
goals that you want to accomplish for
yourself that if you were living this
life you would be ecstatic get a little
bit excited about the life you're about
to build for yourself make a list of all
your goals step two what are the habits
that will help you accomplish those
goals this is where people fall down
it's great to have aspirations and goals
but what are you supposed to do what are
the daily habits if you want to
accomplish some far-out goal it's gonna
be collection of you getting up every
day and working on that goal every day
making sure that what is in your
schedule right if you planned out your
week including weekends including all
your personal time we're planning out of
personal time if you want to have a
great relationship with your husband
wife girlfriend boyfriend whoever you
need time to relax you need time to play
League of Legends whatever the thing is
whatever makes you happy like if your
life looked like this I would be happy
and then putting in the blocks what are
the habits and put those into your
calendar so this Monday here's what
you're gonna do Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday Saturday and Sunday so
that by the time you end up looking at
your weekly calendar when you look at
those activities the habits you're gonna
be building what you are actually going
to be doing executing on on a daily
basis you ask yourself here are my goals
here's my schedule than my habits do
they align do they map right do my
actions map to my ambitions and if not
continue to adjust and tweak but you
need to set down on paper in your
calendar the habits the daily habits
that if you did this every day it would
lead to you accomplishing all of your
goals and step number three is schedule
them in and do the
like just put them in your calendar and
then start doing them because
entrepreneurs especially we love to plan
right we love to plan planning so much
fun planning the dream life is amazing
thinking about what our life is gonna be
thinking about our goals in the world we
want to build and all of our genius
products and services it's amazing we
just bliss out thinking about what we
want to build you can actually do it
right we're too often what happens is
you create a schedule you create a plan
and then after two days in you're
questioning the plan and you're
rethinking it and you're back to
strategizing back to planning you need
to do what I call the 595 rule 5% of
your time should be on planning should
be on thinking should be on strategizing
and 95% of your time is on doing doing
doing the thing and if some things don't
work and you need to adjust and you need
to strategize great the strategy is
super important the planning is super
important it's not just doing with no
plan you're not just running around like
a chicken with his head cut off you're
not just doing stuff you're doing work
that is based off of your plane but most
people flip it most people entrepreneurs
flipper you spend way way way way way
too much planning and then left I'm
actually doing and so 95 percent of your
time doing five percent of your time
planning you're adjusting your you're
tweaking your scene as a schedule work
if you're not you're seeing once a
quarter once a month does what I've
lined up for me is it actually working
is it helped me get closer to my goals
or I'm not making any progress or none
then you tweak and adjust but if you
spent five percent of your time planning
and 95 percent of your time actually
doing holy cow you would move so much
closer to actually accomplishing your
goals stop overthinking things schedule
them in and do so that's a three-step
process to schedule for success I hope
you follow it I wish you the best of
luck it works it works just just try it
try it try it for 30 days try it for 30
days and you will get results if you
just follow the plane I'm frustrated cuz
I want you to win because I see so many
people with massive talent plays small
forever end up being an accountant or
air conditioning repairman hating their
life when they have massive talent and
this is it this is the path this is a
secret schedule for success
I want you to win I've got a really
special bonus clip that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that question of
the day I want to know what is the
single biggest change that you need to
make to your schedule let me know put in
the comments below
another quick story so I didn't have
money for a car and my x19
with a hole in the floorboard had died
and so I literally the way I got my car
was I saw a car that was stranded on the
side of the road this old Camaro and I
forget exactly how but I figured out
which bank had had put the money up for
it for somebody to buy and I called the
bank and I said would you let me pick up
the payments on this
you know only I need you to lower the
payments down a little bit and they said
yes so I had this you know nineteen
eighty-something
um Trans Am that I was able to use but
the point being that you just have to do
things you never think you're gonna have
to do in order to survive and get
through it um you know those first
couple months I remember thinking to
myself I'm in business in two months now
you know I remember getting to the point
where I had $15,000 in sales probably
six months into the company and I'm
still living in the [ __ ] and
thinking okay I can do this I can do
this and along the way it was it was
lots of trial and error you know there
were things that were new to me things
that were terrifying to me things that
would just I would break out into a
sweat but I always remember going into
my customers and just trying to be
brutally honest and say to them if I can
help you right if I can bring value if I
can make your company more competitive
more profitable will you work with me
and you don't have to put money I'll do
the work to prove it and if I get it
done then we'll met you know we'll
figure it all out you know or they agree
to a price and then they'll pay it at
that point and one by one I just kept on
making customers happy and lost some you
know for everyone I lost picked up three
and I got I was so nervous about the
whole thing that you know I just I
couldn't imagine slowing down you know
and so people talked about you know life
family balance I had done I mean I
literally remember dating some girl this
is truth and it was like we'd been
dating a couple years like it mark your
so when do your work I mean I want to
pick a fence I want a house I want kids
you know I mean you it's me or your job
and I was like or me or your company and
I was like what's your name again I'm
like if you don't know me well enough by
now
there was no balance so what advice
would you have for a up-and-coming
screenwriter and director producer for
like younger generations run in the
other direction is this a drug and
unless you want to breathe it live it
get rejected be being told no constantly
day in and day out beat down to the
ground stomped if you can take that then
go but I would say run in the opposite
direction because you keep your head on
[Music]
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
up or that would be like a little beacon
now if you want more done Tapani we did
a top 10 rules video on him the link is
right there next to me go watch it I
think you're gonna enjoy continue to
believe and I'll see you there a monk
that tells you he's never questioned the
path or never thought of leaving is
lying to you
we live our lives like we're gonna live
forever but the truth is we don't live
forever